battle and when are their standards too
high
i think their standards are too high
when it becomes
unattainable okay
and um
illogical
as far as when they should settle
i can't answer that but with regards to
standards being too high i feel like if
something's unattainable then your
standards are too high just by default
okay what do you guys think
i don't necessarily think our standards
are too high
i think like so
you should be typically
uh being of a virgin as a woman
before you actually like before you
actually have sex with a man be thinking
about putting a ring on it
and i would always say that right
say that
sex before marriage bro like oh you're
saying sex before marriage is important
no i'm saying
you shouldn't be having sex before i got
you i'm
going to say you're going to start from
now on no no no no i'm saying the reason
why girls should practice
marriage before sex is because the other
way around disadvantages them
it doesn't disadvantage me i i am
completely in my zone when you don't
want arcs for commitment yeah i don't i
don't need it like it's not
you know i mean it's not i don't have to
spend money on you i don't have to be
thinking about you i don't have to do
like do you know what i mean so it's
worse for you if we don't have a
commitment
so women should not sleep with men
before they are married yes but the
bible said that the quran
if they're virgins but the problem is
you have women that you know get ran
through
and then ask the guy to wait and i'm not
sure that's the best strategy but you
said as well um our connections are
built through sex and sex is a very
important part
what
what happens for the divorce money
because what if the thing is [ __ ] i've
waited
you've got a big o ring
your sex is dead okay the penalty would
you how would you know
how would you know it's bad sex if
you've never had sex with anyone else
unless like like that was you'd
for one of two reasons that you're
comparing them to another guy or your
friends are telling you stuff he's not
yeah my friends is probably saying
you're meant to maybe some things are
meant to happen at this at a point in
sex but then you can grow with someone
when it comes to sex isn't it like so
you can have sex with someone for the
first time and it's not that good but
then once you stay it's called practice
ladies
you're gonna miss a lot of good sex if
you do that no no no because you know
what it is like i think feminism got
confused yeah they're like oh men were
sitting down in a dark corner or
cuddling together thinking how can we
screw over women instead of thinking it
as men actually love their women and
think how can we best protect our women
and our daughters the best way is for
her to be married my daughter to be
married with a man that i've
vetted i've i've made sure he's all
right
yes it's high pergamus but i've vetted
him even like you know i mean we're
we're marrying a family to another
family of two um would you call it
two decent families
we're not just marrying the person we're
marrying the family as well so we're
married so now when you're 89 and you've
got all your kids and your aunties
around you're not lonely you don't have
the cat around you you know i'm trying
to say you enjoy your life and fulfill
your life because that's what the main
purpose of life isn't it to reproduce
the happiest life for a woman is simply
that she doesn't run through loads of
men she gets married
she has a loads of kids
she gets to have grandkids and then
later on she gets spoiled by standing in
her living room and she's got
20 30 people that have all just come
from her and at the end of the day
it's not that well ultimately
women
they can't have they can't have been
[ __ ] down by so many different men and
then expect to have a man take them
seriously in a long-term relationship
it's okay making it's okay making the
man wait ever so slightly but that's if
he knows you don't have a history of
being run through by loads of different
men i think that alone is going to give
men the security to say right look i'm
now willing to wait a little bit because
i know that this woman's heart is in it
for the right reason and now i know that
i can wife her and we can do it for the
right reason we can actually have kids
and we can have a long-lasting
relationship personally i do agree with
you all that actually the the
government's involvement to me is
[ __ ] as well i hate it but
the sentiment of it
is far more biologically
beneficial to you
but men men will opt in as long as you
don't have that background because you
don't have that history and as long as
loyalty is there first and foremost and
that you will treat man so you will
treat your men
as men don't wrong they have to be men
in the first place and by men i mean
actual masculine men they have to have
the right frame they have to have the
finances in order but
as long as they can see that you have
the right history you have the right
motive and then the loyalty is there all
together
i think we could all agree in here that
a relationship is now going to last and
it's going to be fruitful forever what's
more what's more important a low body
count or loyalty
what's more important
i don't think i need to pick either one
they tend to be the same i'm going to
say they kind of they go hand in hand
because if a girl has a higher body
count it's more baggage it's more excess
he has to deal with it's more like i
hate this term but like alpha widows
yeah it's basically like the x that the
girl can't get over but there's more of
them
the more people she slept with i do
agree with certain points that you said
about game i do agree with body count
and i do
i was raised on women shouldn't get run
through and i do agree with that and
i'll preach that to my daughters
but i don't what i don't agree with is
the perfect
family the scenario the greatest thing
for a woman is when she's standing in
her living room with 30 people
celebrating her
yeah for some people yeah for some
people that is that is their life goal
i don't think
my my i've got a few people in my family
that can't have kids
so that's the exception that's the
exception and that's an exception so is
to say is to say she can't have kids her
life is any less fulfilled
than
my other auntie that has got that maybe
maybe but she's living her best life on
in foreign like is she she's had she's
she's had to adjust the ultimate you've
got yeah i hear you so we can adjust and
i'm i don't think her life is any less
fulfilled no it's not it's not going to
be in it it's not going to be any less
fulfilled i mean technically it will be
saying she has been through probably
periods of her life but she's one of the
kids right
but but again i mean that is the
exception to the rule and it doesn't
mean she can't be happy but she's not
going to be as happy now that's just the
sad truth of it right but if if you're a
woman i mean to go back to your previous
point
what would a woman want more than to
later on be able to say that they're a
grandmother great grandmother with loads
of loads of kids load of people that
have come from there what will i know
you said that that's not every woman's
goal what goal would you say a woman
would value more than that long term
that society hasn't told us you should
have yeah i'm
like i want i want to cut the 30
grandkids 30 great-grandkids down to
like eight nine because the cost of
living out here is crazy yeah that's a
little christmas present but the point
is the point is if women doesn't
prioritize a family she ends up unhappy
in the long term in general
like
because this is when you survey women
because it's it's all fun and games when
you're still hot right and you still
look good right and you still get
attention from men but at some point
that goes away like no guys are lining
up to date 50 year olds yeah and you're
gonna live to be 90. go ahead yeah sorry
and we have that window so that's why we
want that commitment fertility window
yeah yeah so we need to
we need to
optimize in that and try and
find that commitment when we're in that
window so then
so women want women are nurturing they
want to have kids naturally
naturally naturally you do
but i believe the only reason why some
women will say they don't and i i
personally believe i'm i'm yet to be
convinced otherwise is because modern
day social conditioning society has
convinced you that's not your ultimate
goal but if you actually
walk into a dark room with nobody in
there by yourself completely quite and
ask yourself what do you want what does
your biology want i think you know the
answer when you ask girls that are 18
and they're graduating high school they
all want to be married with kids that's
the first thing yeah but who sold them
that dream
as well it's definitely not society you
have feminism pushing you can get your
own bag female empowerment like i've
been told from the youngest age that i
can do whatever i want society's telling
you that you should have this big career
yeah and make it on your own and
[ __ ] that's
not what you're doing you're just gonna
if you're gonna be
like a
a high up lawyer with loads of money you
may have loads of money but you'll be
lonely because you won't have
your children you get a couple more
holidays a year out of your money so
[ __ ] what at the end of the day what
does it matter to you if you've not got
a family that's ultimately what you want
to have children
i mean it's the gift that we have yeah
that's not how to procreate like you're
breeding machines
that's literally what you're
biologically designing
i know this but i want to ask you guys
some